because I'm Batman we got some Batman
news to talk about supposedly Robert
Pattinson --zz Batman movie is getting a
TV show spin-off about Gotham PD a new
Gotham show Jim Gordon there's some new
details here to uncover and this is
actually official not some leaker rumor
is this is a more not more doom cocking
Matt Reeves talked about it HBO max had
a press release let's cover this before
we do that though I did want to shout
out our patreon page we haven't done
that at all this month so far so guys
over at our patreon we do a weekly Q&A
podcast go check us out over there you
submit questions we do podcast based off
of them the biggest draw would be the
fact that we do music and TV show
reactions many of those shows have
reaction highlights included with the
option to do a watch along as well and
the shows that have reaction highlights
are supernatural Doctor Who a hero
academia attack on Titan JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure Death Note Hunter hunter
promise Neverland Code Geass Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood just started a
violet ever garden he just started up
Demon Slayer one punch man and then
there are shows where we only have the
watch a long option for them and those
are agents of shield and yes all of
Gotham I recently just finished all of
Gotham and that's why I'm excited to
talk about this piece of news okay I
actually really love that Gotham show I
think it's actually a pretty underrated
series kind of gets silly at times
kenick it can't be sure but I actually
thought it's really well written for the
most part and I think it's really well
acted and this style and direction let's
see if I can wrap my head around it
already new Gotham show so the HBO max
press release says this the
groundbreaking television series to be
written by a winter is set in the world
Reeves is creating for the Batman
feature film and will build upon the
motion pictures examination of the
anatomy of corruption in Gotham City
ultimately launching a new Batman
universe across multiple platforms the
series provides an unprecedented
opportunity to extend the world
established in the movie and further
explore the myriad of compelling and
complex characters of Gotham this marks
the first television project for Reeves
under his recently announced overall
deal with the Warner Brothers television
group and here's what Reeves had to say
this is an amazing opportunity not only
to expand have no idea opportunity not
only to expand the vision of the world I
am creating in the film but to explore
it in the kind of depth and detail that
only a long-form format can afford sweet
and getting to work with the incredibly
talented Terence winter will talk a
little bit more about him in a sec who
has written so insightful e and
powerfully about worlds of crime and
corruption is an absolute dream and this
will also introduce the Ben Affleck HBO
Mac series and and then we will get
Michael Keaton to be the Nick Fury and
flashpoint will get involved and tie all
this pretty soon you're gonna have to
watch the HBO max shows if you want to
understand the DCU movies Elseworlds
good luck guys this is just gonna make
matters worse
and then this article goes on to further
say what makes this an exciting process
it is that it sounds like it's in the
vein of the excellent comic series
Gotham Central which I did have comics
of but never read which was a street
level view of Gotham from the
perspective of cops and detectives it's
a great way to expand the Batman
universe without requiring Batman to
show up we got an immensely silly
version of this with the Fox series
Gotham but now there's an opportunity to
do it right
Josh Shire fired mother-effer
ouch ooh don't you gonna take that yeah
because a lot of people share that I
think there's a lot of rich rich
episodes and I think the fans of Gotham
that series would agree that's why
they're fans it's also a bit of a tell
that were media isn't putting this
series on DC Universe where they put
other DC properties but instead of
pushing it on HBO max which will also be
home to the Snyder it cut said it once
that Snyder cut thing came out and
everyone was like oh [ __ ] people care
about HBO max we need to do more decent
stuff you're only got about
I wouldn't be surprised that DC Universe
is dead within a year or transitions to
comics only yeah I think they would just
put the shows from DC Universe totally
on HBO backs as for this entitled series
set in Gotham I'm curious to see how
much crossover we'll have with the
Batman obviously getting Robert
Pattinson to guest star may be a bit of
a stretch would it matter Yves is
working directly on this if they like
each other that much and if the show has
movie caliber production quality and if
Robert Pattinson really is proud of the
work he did he might like agents of
shield how that started yeah like Joss
Whedon directed AOS the pilot right like
I believe he directed the pilot yeah I
mean his his team was heavily involved
they did not do a lot in the movies to
accept the show my point being you know
like Kevin Feige is so much associated
with Marvel we don't really have that
kind of name recognition with the DC
Universe at the moment this really feels
like Matt Reeves is Batman and it seems
like a lot of people signed up for
mattresses Batman because of the script
that he wrote for this I think Robert
Pattinson is included in that so I'd
imagine it might be out of anyone to be
likely to happen I feel like getting
Robert Pattinson to show up in this
series is likely to happen yeah it would
be hard at all actually especially if
you're gonna have like jeffrey wright
playing Commissioner Gordon still and
all that well I think I mean yeah it
says right here too that Jeffrey Wright
most likely Commissioner will be a
reoccurring character I don't think it
would be wise on their end to do another
Gotham show where Jim Gordon is like
yeah
obviously he would be a reoccurring
character even in the comics I'm if I'm
not mistaken he's a reoccurring
character
I believe Renee Montoya is actually one
of the lead characters in the Gotham
central comic maybe they could use it as
a slight chance to tie it in a bit they
get Rosie Perez in there but then you'd
have to work with the birds-of-prey
storyline and how that ended on they're
just gonna woke upmy Batman Batman man
and screwing everything over so I think
their best bet would still be as much as
I liked Rosie Perez I think that their
best bet would still be if they have
Renee Montoya to do a difference Renee
Montoya and I think too that
automatically what would make this
different than Gotham the Fox show is
Gotham was a pre Lou
leading into Bruce Wayne becoming Batman
in the final episode that's what it was
leading into ultimately and then here it
sounds like this show would be existing
on the same timeline within whenever the
movies are taking place yeah exactly so
you already have a Batman fully formed
kind of like agents of shield but more
involved yeah yeah exactly agents of
shield if they actually had a movie
universe that really wanted to play back
and forth with it exactly and I think
we'll make this cool is that with it
being HBO max one thing that the Gotham
show and I'm not gonna be making like a
giant comparison game here with the
Gotham show that I thought was really
fascinating was that it was on Fox but
it was also extremely gory at times like
very vibe shown you images of like you
kept likening it to like American Horror
stit was yeah it's like a Ryan Murphy
show it yeah there is some really wacky
like crazy gory stuff in there now with
this being Gotham the the worst city in
the world to live in I don't know why
anyone lives there huhai and it being on
HBO max you can you could be further
more violent than what Netflix was able
to do with the Marvel shows oh yeah you
can have the F words you can have you
can you can have it be like a hard-r
television show when you can probably
push and explore some pretty tough ideas
- exactly I don't know I just associate
HBO with that level of like let's dig in
and really get into some messed-up
territory and you know Gotham being as
terrible of a city as it seems like it
isn't with the level of crime from both
the street level to the super villainous
like there's a lot to explore I would
imagine of course and then you got
Terence winter who's really bringing
this show to life who has you know vinyl
out there right now and he did he did
Boardwalk Empire I recently finished The
Sopranos I think he was one of the main
writers actually and then the wolf of
Wall Street he wrote the screenplay for
that as well so this guy 50 Cent's
bulletproof video this is a gonna be a
police procedural show that explores the
criminal underbelly evidently
this guy knows how to write about
corruption yeah in the world he knows
how to do all that really well in the
seam apply it with the comic book medium
and also getting this different side of
Matt Reeves because when we see this
movie
everyone's gonna be associating like
Matt Reeves the director of the Batman
yes he excels at these movies that are
technically big studio films yet he
knows how to make them very
character-driven and pretty grounded
like the smallest scale film other than
the pallbearer lose on the other than
that movie let me in is probably the
smallest scale movie he's ever done
working on this or the way he always
great a thematic exploration making
things grounded in character exploration
I'm excited that Matt Reeves is directly
involved with this adapting oh yeah and
it suggests a certain level of steady
continuity you know because a lot of
times I feel like you'll hear that like
oh there's a spin-off show based on this
movie and you'll get excited but then
you'll see it you'll be like I can tell
it's not the same folks and so yeah
having this level of unity in terms of
the you know foundation seems like an
inspiring thing especially with Matt
Reeves track record what's sounding cool
about the way the whole Batman thing is
shaping up is like the the way they've
been saying this is a trilogy this whole
Universal I feel like the way to
separate this it's like you got the Dark
Knight trilogy which is known as Nolan's
Batman you got Batman within the DC
extended universe and now you have mater
eases the Batman world yeah and I feel
like that's gonna be the easiest way to
define this specific umbrella with
having this show and then having the
Batman movie on top of it or the trilogy
that they're setting up that's like with
the HBO maximum with the money that they
want to put that they're putting in HBO
maximum how they're finding their
funding the damn Snyder this could be a
cool opportunity to get Colin Farrell's
penguin in here involved as well I don't
want them to just only do like what we
saw in Gotham but also only the famous
rope gallery villains but I think you
can make a really hardcore character
study focused show about these cops
that's not gonna have to be heavily
reliant like yes I want them to infuse
Commissioner Gordon I want them to have
some of the Batman rogues gallery
villains of course I want all that them
to make Gotham police procedural but
with none of the things you want to see
it
cops that are totally made-up and only
the cops and only she will cry this
guy's wife is happy Batman at all
Terence winter is doing this odds are
the main male character is cheating on
his wife you want a certain level of
Batman eNOS but not you know to the
degree where it's just could have been
another movie er yeah and plus - you
have a lot of discussions about the
police going on in the world right now
and comic books I think are a fertile
ground for those kinds of allegorical
explorations that are also flashy and
fun that's why I think they should make
all the characters white definitely may
call the cops white and then the one cop
who stands up against the injustice is
just messin whoa guys I'm just trying to
provoke I'm excited for this yeah I
think this could be something really
special let's face it I don't feel like
too many comparisons will be drawn to
the Gotham show on Fox because that show
really dipped in viewers it seems like
it has its cult audience yeah it wasn't
a huge show the main thing I'm surprised
about by this is just that it's not a
Zack Snyder bad averse cuz you know like
they've dumped that money under the
Steyr cutting there's all that talk
about like well maybe Ben Affleck will
put the cowl back on J or the double
down on Matt Reeves is like super cool
is not exactly what I expected this
could have been part of that when you
got the rumor mills going on about HBO
max working on a Batman show maybe
through though the telephone it turn
into an Affleck so right because of the
Snyder cut but really this might have
been what they were talking about anywho
guys are you excited for this show you
said it's gonna be on HBO max leave your
thoughts down below do you want Robert
Pattinson just take over the series and
just star in it throughout let's hope
you don't say yes to that subscribe to
the reel rejects click that notification
bell last but not least Michael B I got
a shout out our homeboy Omni media do
yourself a favor follow him on his
YouTube shadow I want to be very
specific about this because he is
covering so much DC content covering
Doom Patrol right now DC star girl right
now he's doing a whole bunch of shows
and his commentary is frickin dynamite I
want this guy to become a more famous
youtuber because he is so good at what
he does and I'm not just saying that
cause he's pleasure
patreon page I'll actually a lot of
times I'll be cleaning and I'll just put
on one of his videos and I'll just
listen to his commentary and then steal
it
yeah then I steal his opinions that I
put them here and then I'm like where
are more people follow Tommy really need
some more respect from you guys but
seriously follow the guy thank you I
mean subscribe to his channel today